hallo mein name ist lucanet ich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video ages
dienstag meine damen und herren das
heißt wir spielen minecraft beta in der
minecraft beta in der minecraft beta
let's get started
wir waren in der letzten folge hier
stehen geblieben dass wir hier irgendwas
die kühe fakt mich echt ab da unten hast
du irgendeine meinung dazu dass du
meinst hier unten einfach schwimmen zu
dürfen
ich wollte in diesem part auf jeden fall
mal das eisen was sich unten mitgenommen
habe in den ofen packen und mir damit
eine passende spitzhacke und passende
schwert machen so dass wir heute
vielleicht mal ein bisschen in höhlen
gehen können davor setzen allerdings
hier mal einfach ein paar bäume hin und
hoffen dass sie dann irgendwie die tage
so ein bisschen wachsen werden weil ich
ja noch ein bisschen holz brauche für
meine baumstämme die ich hier so an den
seiten runterlassen gehen wollen möchte
tun haben sehr gutes deutschland vida
loca dafür fälle ich jetzt auch hier
einfach mal kurz einen baum ab guck mal
da gucke ich gerade weg und dann gucken
die schafe die gucke ich gerade zu den
schafen hin und dann gucken was sind das
für scharfe mann der höhleneingang hier
sieht einfach ultra coole diesen jahren
davor allerdings mache ich jetzt erstmal
den baum noch vor kaputt wir natürlich
auch überall schön die bäume
nachpflanzen und dass wir nachher das
ist halt das coole in minecraft in
schwanfeld einen baum kriegt aber
setzlinge für irgendwie zehn millionen
andere und wieso wird denn schon wieder
nacht ich hätte mich heute vielleicht
echt mal erst darum kümmern müssen dass
ich mir ein vernünftiges zu hause mache
bevor ich mich um das eisen kümmere weil
ich jetzt wo soll ich denn schlafen ein
paar schicken den später hört sich jetzt
vielleicht bescheuert an allerdings
schlafe ich beim mops bonner weil das
der einzige raum ist der ein bisschen
hoch ist so glaube ich keinem ob spawnen
sollten wenn ich jetzt allerdings neben
der horde von spinnen aufwache dann
heule ich mein ich glaube es hat
geklappt ich habe jetzt immer ganz kurz
den mops bonner hier so ein bisschen
freier hingelegt und platziere jetzt die
an der wand auch wieder eine verarbeitet
stellt dir denn auf einmal zum sport
mein gott ich oh mein gott es kam dann
luca ok ok just for fun
okay okay wenn ihr euch auch so eine
tolle skizzen kaufen wollt dann besuch
doch vielleicht einfach mal den nutzer
windows ok wieso sbz direkt vor meiner
schnauze verfickte spinne gisborne also
ich meine vielleicht spornt gleich
einfachen scriba neben mir und da unten
schwimmt schon wieder ne kuh ich könnte
heulen was ist denn mit meinem leben wir
nehmen hier vorne mal noch schöne ganzen
setzlinge mit die hier noch rumliegen
pflanzen natürlich auch hier direkt
wieder hinter das wort aber hier kann
ich nicht an den das hat super geklappt
einen idealen hier runter zu klettern
die ich nehme mal einfach das eisen mit
was ihr vorne noch in der band ist und
begebe mich dann direkt wieder nach
hause okay okay da will man wirklich
ganz kurz nach hause laufen und was will
ich dann hier vorne in der ecke freunde
meine damen und herren kann es denn sein
dass wir direkt wieder einen mops bonner
hier haben ich habe mir den sieg nicht
ausgesucht oder so aber wir haben zwei
männer direkt neben verdammt nochmal
einander wir können so eine riesige
vergibt die mob ich muss erstmal ganz
auf mein leben klarkommen wahrscheinlich
finde ich jetzt auf nachhauseweg wieder
zwei maps bonner ich meine ich will mich
ja gar nicht beschweren das ist ja schön
und gut allerdings ist es einfach immer
so ein adrenalin moment wenn man denkt
okay man läuft ganz normal durch eine
höhe und auf einmal beim spender spenden
oder so der einem hotspot von uns ist
also hier und der andere ist dorthin das
heißt wir können die locker irgendwie
zusammen laufen lassen mit irgendwelchen
flüssen unter ihre schon alter ich denke
glaube ich viel zu groß für dieses
projekt ihr seht halt wöchentlich immer
nur so 56 minuten von dem projekt und
eigentlich geht eine datei wenn ich das
tier aufnehmen immer so 30 40 minuten
also ich schneid das quasi dann immer
runter allerdings können wie es ja
demnächst vielleicht auch so machen wenn
ich dann beispielsweise so riesige
wasserzuflüsse mache wie beispielsweise
für die mob farben dass wir dann einfach
sagen ja luca da macht halt ein bisschen
aufs spiel so dass du nicht im video
quasi die ganze zeit da ist im baum
gewachsen
wir sind jetzt offiziell gärtner
vielleicht mache ich demnächst einfach
mal ein paar sachen off screen so dass
wir uns dann in der folge nicht die
ganze zeit damit aufhalten dass ich
irgendwelche komischen zehn milliarden
arten von verschiedenen stein unter der
erde abbau wir bauen jetzt hier einfach
mal an den seiten diese baumstämme so
hoch wie ich mir das vorgestellt hatte
und ich glaube ich brauche definitiv
noch viel mehr baumstämme als ich denke
ich habe jetzt einfach mal 35 holz ab
gefällt ihr seht doch schon hier wie
viel ich auch schon wieder nachgepflanzt
haben und wie viel ich erst mal ab
gefällt habe also bauen wir jetzt hier
den einen holz stumpf noch so ein
bisschen weiter hoch dass wir hier auf
der höhe sind und jetzt auf der anderen
wird es schon wieder nacht hier noch
weiter hoch bauen dann auf der anderen
seite wieder ins wasser springen und
genau an dieser stelle glaube ich noch
weiter hochbahn ein genau nicht an
dieser stelle schön ins bettchen legen
und hoffen dass ich vielleicht nicht
gerade auf wache wenn ich sehe wie
wieder den monstern bin genau hat glaube
ich wieder alles ganz gut geklappt ich
kann nicht immer gott warum warum warum
bist du darum ist landes spiele warum
ist da eine verdammte spinne warum ist
eine gottverdammte spinne gewesen
freunde mein herz mir ich hab mich übel
erschrocken gerade immer wenn ich
verdammt noch mal nur schlafen gehen
möchtest bond direkt vor der tür meines
mops bonners tür meines mops bonners was
eigentlich nur dort ist das vor und
einfach eine spinne freunde was soll die
scheiße warum bond da unten bitte eine
spinne ich hatte da eigentlich alles
ausgeleuchtet an dieser stelle durch das
video auch beende meine damen und herren
mein essen kommt gleich an deswegen muss
ich jetzt gerade beenden wir haben in
dieser folge einen neuen mops bonner
entdeckt wir haben ein paar baumstämme
hochgezogen und ich hab mich mal wieder
erschrocken wenn euch das gefallen da
freue ich mich über eine bewertung
schreibt mir weiterhin sachen die ich
bauen soll tipps socken farben und pizza
lieblingsrezept in die kommentare und
dann halte ich jetzt endlich meine
schnauze